I love being in the middle of two
friends fighting because they both keep
coming to me burn deros are at this bar
drinking heavily at a tie bar and then
they're like Joe Liz come get us he goes
all right are you ready to go I'm sober
so I'm not gonna sit at a bar with you
guys he's like just come it's a five
minute walk by the time he gets back
he's where the were you that's what
bird says immediately we were sitting
there for two hours he's like two of you
left an hour ago they're so into it
they're like this guy out I'm like I
know he sucks then the other guy's like
I know he's the worst I'm like oh so bad
this pizza's coming and Joe's like yeah
whatever we got pizzas too it's no big
deal and he goes you got pizzas you said
Thai and he goes I didn't say Ty I never
I don't like Thai food so I never would
have wanted Thai because
food and is that burden uh Joe just
screaming each other's faces not each
other's faces Joel is like dude what is
this fight about I just hacked on some
pizzas yeah to whatever you got does it
bother you when you give someone that
and they don't appreciate it no you mean
like chill list by the way for eight
Pizza later
[Laughter]